ne pas avoir accès à l'eau potable en
france en 2020
une situation inimaginable qui pourtant
celle dans laquelle se trouvent de
nombreux guadeloupéens des habitants de
l'île compte régulièrement des coupures
d'eau qui peuvent durer plusieurs
semaines voire plusieurs mois provoquant
une profonde exaspération
bah oui on est en colère parce que on
paye quand même des factures d'eau
franchement et c'est pas top quoi parce
qu on a besoin d'eau dans la vie
courante a besoin d'autres dans le
contexte de la crise sanitaire actuelle
ces difficultés d'approvisionnement en
pose de nombreuses questions au chu de
guadeloupe comme dans la plupart des
établissements de santé
on demande aux patients de venir avec
leurs propres ou tous témoignent de la
complexité de respecter les gestes
barrière dans ces conditions tout ce que
faut se laver les mains faut avoir une
bonne hygiène comme on fait pour faire
sans eau surtout des personnes âgées
tout ça ils peuvent pas transporter de
l'eau c'est pas tout en étant dit je
n'avais que vous transportez pour eux
donc ils sont plus depuis de nombreuses
années le réseau de distribution d'eau
insulaire est régulièrement décriée en
raison de sa trop grande vétusté dans le
viseur la gestion chaotique du syndicat
intercommunal d'alimentation en eau et
d'assainissement de la guadeloupe qui
gère le réseau depuis près de 50 ans
son ancien directeur hamilius hernandez
a été condamné l'an passé à trois ans de
prison dont deux de sursis et 150 mille
euros d'amendé pour détournement de
fonds et favoritisme dans l'attribution
des marchés publics le syndicat est
régulièrement accusé par la classe
politique locale de détourner l'argent
destiné à entretenir le réseau
le problème c'est que nous avons un
passif mafieux scrupuleux qui à nova
dillon d'étonner environ un milliard
d'euros c'est à dire que les
consommateurs les usagers de l'eau sur
la facture d'eau ont été ponctionnés
chaque mois dumas chaque fois qu'a bonne
facture les des pensionnés la partie qui
devait réparer les canalisations et
cette part active au lieu de servir à la
réparation des canalisations
cette partie a été détourné malgré un
rapport gouvernemental sur la question
publié en mai 2010
dénonçant une crise de l'eau systémique
sur l'île et le lancement de nombreux
chantiers afin de réhabiliter le réseau
de distribution de nombreux
guadeloupéens n'ont toujours pas accès à
l'eau potable
signe de la gravité de la situation le
préfet de guadeloupe
philippe gustin a profité de l'état
d'urgence pour réquisitionner la filiale
locale de suez est une société suisse
afin de cartographier les fuites et de
réduire les pertes
un travail titanesque le coût des
travaux pour la réhabilitation de
l'ensemble du système de distribution
d'eau est estimé à près d'un milliard
d'euros